[Music]
episode four of wandavision is another
offering of surreal confusing television
that audiences clearly cannot get enough
of
this genre-blending marvel cinematic
universe edition continues to impress
as well as confound here's some insight
into the end of the latest installment
the fourth wandavision episode opens
with a flashback to the avengers
endgame moment when hulk snapped
everyone back into existence
an event known as the blip from monica
rambo's perspective
she awakens in a hospital where her mom
maria rambo from captain marvel
received successful cancer treatment
just before thanos eliminated half of
all life in the universe
frantic monica learns that five years
have passed and that her
mother is long gone thanks to her
cancer's return
nevertheless she presses on returning to
work at sort
an organization for which her mom served
as director monica's first assignment
back takes her to west view new jersey
where a person in the fbi's witness
protection program went missing
she arrives on the scene to meet with
agent jimmy wu of ant-man and the wasp
fame and attempts to get a glimpse
inside the town from a distance
monica soon finds herself sucked into
its energy field
and unwittingly adopts the persona
geraldine
as we've seen in previous episodes by
the time the credits roll
wanda shoots monica out of westview as
she did
at the end of one division episode 3 but
monica
appears to have all of her memories
intact
in past one division installments the
show has dropped minor hints as to who's
on the outside
attempting to break into this pocket
reality given the organization's logo
has appeared all over the program at
this point
it should come as no surprise that sword
is behind these various plans
although their success is middling at
best one division episode 4
at the very least gives everyone a fresh
and informative perspective
as to where sword's presence in west
view came from and explains their desire
to snap
wanda out of her trance first and
foremost when monica arrives at the
energy field surrounding west view
she flies a miniature sword helicopter
right into it
this is the same one that wanda finds in
her front yard early on in the second
episode
given a dated appearance to match the
60s vibe later on
jimmy wu and astrophysicist darcy lewis
from the first two thor movies tried to
communicate with wanda via radio to no
avail
just as episode 2 depicted finally
there's the mysterious sewer dweller
whose true identity is sword agent
franklin
under westfield's spell his hazmat suit
was swapped for a beekeeper outfit
and the wire rope connecting him to the
sword response base was transformed into
a period-appropriate
jump rope considering their heavy
military presence in the region it's
unlikely that sword will leave wanda
and her new home alone any time soon
although
with her power levels hardly scratching
the surface of their fullest potential
they would be wise to tread lightly
while this wandavision episode largely
focuses on sword's involvement in
wanda's sitcom world
it also explains quite a bit about the
town of westview and its residents
as revealed by jimmy wu early on the odd
town is somehow very stringent about who
enters and who leaves not to mention
everyone around it seems to have
collective amnesia about its existence
with a police officer from the town of
eastview denying it's a real place
while standing next to its welcome sign
thanks to darcy's input
it's discovered that westview gives off
a television broadcast frequency
entwined with cosmic microwave
background radiation
or cmbr allowing them to observe it on
an antique tv
as if it's a classic television series
sword's acting director
tyler hayward calls cmbr relic radiation
dating back to the big bang
so you're saying the universe created a
sitcom starring two avengers
it's a working theory in a startling
revelation it's deduced that some of the
program's mainstays are living beings
trapped inside this simulated reality
with the notable exceptions of agnes and
dottie we discover that they all have
true identities and lives away from
westview
details of which sword are able to
uncover with relative ease
whether or not they're aware of it or if
they're under some kind of spell that
makes them act accordingly
remains to be seen and so does the
identity of the fbi's missing witness
in the closing moments of the episode we
get a glimpse at what seems to be
vision's true form
and it's absolutely horrifying he
appears not as the vibrant
lively synthesis we've seen him as
previously but rather as the colorless
husk
thanos reduced him to in infinity war
with a gaping hole where the mind stone
used to be
this seems to indicate that he's still
very much deceased
with someone apparently puppeteering his
body and altering his appearance to ease
wanda's trauma over his demise
it's cruel twisted and heartbreaking but
hey
that's one division in a shocking
revelation at the end of the episode
monica now back on the outside of
westview and free of her geraldine
identity
tells her fellow sword associates what
she thinks is going on
it's all wonderful
to someone on the outside it may appear
as if wanda is in complete control of
this reality
after all her abilities arguably have
the most potential of the mcu's entire
current roster
however eagle-eyed fans of wandavision
continue to pick up hints
that a larger even more powerful entity
could actually be behind westview's
creation
and is deceiving wanda into believing
she's the one controlling things
for instance there's this exchange
during the planning committee scene in
episode 2.
the devil's in the details bev that's
not the only place he is
that's certainly a decent enough laugh
line for an old sitcom
after all dottie is seen as an
unfriendly and devilish character by the
other ladies on the committee at this
point
however plenty of mcu theorists have
taken this as a clue
that has huge implications for one
division's future specifically that
agnes
may be the mcu version of marvel comics
character agatha harkness
a witch who's been involved in wanda and
visions lives in the past
additionally the arrival of wanda and
vision's kids
tommy and billy also seem to hint that
the devilish marvel comics character
mephisto might not be too far behind
either
will either of these clues pay off in
the next episode maybe
by now we've gotten more than a few
glimpses behind the curtain
and monica's explanation that it's all
wanda definitely fits with what we've
seen
she's the one who rewound time when she
saw the beekeeper in
episode 2. she's the one who blasted
monica out of westview
she seems to be the one who changes
vision's appearance at the end of
episode 4
after we catch sight of his dead-eyed
face and gemla's forehead
after all one of the most famous marvel
comics storylines
involving wanda was house of m in which
she creates a new version of reality as
a way of dealing with the trauma of her
personal life
specifically in response to the
lingering trauma of realizing her
children
tommy and billy aren't real and they
disappear from existence
and we've gotten other hints and
references that seem to point to the
house of m storyline in one division
like house of contempt in french on the
wine bottles label in episode 1
and the butterflies in episode 3 which
recall the mutant butterfly from house
of m
aka leila miller who is immune to the
alternate reality
it's not much of a stretch to surmise
that wanda created westview in a similar
reaction to the trauma of losing vision
to thanos
in infinity war her reaction to seeing
his dead face
in this episode seems to prove that
she's aware of vision's true form and is
doing everything in her power to deny
that reality
and that may include creating and
controlling westview
and the ending of episode 4 where we see
wanda forcefully smashing monica through
walls to maintain her sitcom reality's
illusion
contrasts pretty hard with the ending of
episode 3 in which it's merely implied
that wanda simply ejected monica out of
west view
however with more than half of the nine
episode series left to go
it's a decent enough bet that there's
even more going on underneath the
surface
we're meant to infer that wanda is in
control and being told that
it's all wanda is certainly a good way
to reinforce that idea
but then why are agnes and dottie not
identified with real world counterparts
like most of the other main cast members
is there more to them than meets the eye
or are we just finding clues wherever we
can
trying to stay one step ahead of one
division's showrunners
we'll at least have to wait to see
episode 5 next week to find out
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you